vamos a las noticias de la economía con
Daniela Blandón Daniela Buen día para
usted Hola Buenos días Ángela desde este
sábado desaparecen las cuentas
verificadas de Twitter que no paguen
suscripciones esto ha causado mucho
revuelo mucha polémica ha causado Ángela
Es que después de meses del retraso del
lanzamiento de su servicio Twitter Blue
el multimillonario y los Moss se alista
para cumplir su promesa de que la
celebridad de los periodistas y otras
personas que han sido verificadas de
forma gratuita por años se verán
expuestos a perder su estatus dentro de
la plataforma si no pagan una
suscripción el pasado lunes El Magnate
tuiteó que será glorioso en respuesta a
un usuario que señaló que precisamente
el sábado también es el Día de los
inocentes ahora veamos cuál va a ser el
costo de la suscripción va a oscilar
entre los 8 y los 11 dólares como vemos
dependiendo de si lo utilizan en la
página web o si lo están utilizando en
los sistemas iOS y Android de los
teléfonos celulares por supuesto la
mayoría de la gente lo hace a través de
sus teléfonos celulares van a tener
también la posibilidad de tener una
suscripción anual también hay una
membresía más costosa para las
organizaciones Y es que hemos dice que
está la única manera de frenar los
llamados Bots y también devolver a la
empresa rentable después de años de
pérdidas y del Éxodo de anunciantes que
inició Desde que la compró porque ha
sido tan polémica esta medida Daniela
además de costosa pues Ángela porque hay
quienes dicen que el sello azul le
otorgará estatus a cualquiera que esté
dispuesto a pagar una mínima cantidad y
que eso se presta para suplantaciones y
para proliferación de cuentas como
parodia y esto ya ha ocurrido en el
pasado inclusive ha habido cuentas del
mismo hilo mosk de parodia también hay
algunos usuarios veteranos por ejemplo
incluido la leyenda del Star trek
schatner William chadner de 92 años
quien se ha negado a comprar el servicio
Premium él dice que cómo va a pagar por
un servicio que ha tenido gratis por 15
años a lo que le responde que no Debería
ser tratado diferente simplemente por
ser una celebridad y que se trata de un
tema de igualdad pero también hay otro
punto muy particular Ángela y es que es
cierto que hay cierto desdén por los
medios de comunicación por parte de elon
musk enviamos yo envié un correo
personal a Twitter preguntando por la
verificación para en medios de
comunicación y nos llegó este mensaje
como auto respuesta Pues él mismo le
había anticipado el 19 de marzo que
todas las respuestas a través de este
correo creado para periodistas y van a
ser las mismas el famoso emoticono del
chip de chocolate Bueno la dejo con su
chip de chocolate Daniela pero vamos a
hablar ahora de la zona Euro que toma un
respiro en el alza de precios Tuvo una
caída de recorte en marzo en concreto
los precios al consumidor subieron 6,9%
después de un aumento del 8,5% en
febrero y eso implicó la mayor
desaceleración desde que eurostat
comenzó a recopilar datos en 1991 Pero
eso se debe a los precios de la energía
que han bajado pero hay que también
Hacer una aclaración Es que esto es una
comparación anual es decir este mes
marzo la variación no va a ser tan
grande frente a los precios de hace un
año Porque en ese momento ya se habían
disparado por la guerra no pasaba igual
en los meses anteriores y comparamos
febrero con febrero del año pasado los
precios estaban mucho más bajos y por
eso es que la inflación Ya se está
viendo pues más desacelerada esta
tendencia entonces podría esperarse en
el resto de países la mala noticia del
dato europeo de hoy es que la inflación
subyacente si está acelerándose esta
inflación subyacente es la que no
incluye los precios más volátiles como
los de los alimentos y la energía pero
como una cosa es la que diga lo que
digan las cifras y otra lo que dicen los
ciudadanos vamos a escuchar Qué piensan
algunos de ellos
[Música]
semana semana hay un aumento en los
precios y las cosas son Realmente más
caras es difícil para nosotros obtener
lo que necesitamos estamos comprando
menos cantidades
las subidas de precios nos han impactado
mucho en cuanto a clientes y los que
vienen están contando todos los céntimos
porque hay muy poco poder adquisitivo
miren otros temas me llama mucho la
atención que el Reino Unido es un caso
que se ha convertido casi en una
discusión diaria cada vez que usted y yo
o sus compañeros de economía están en la
mesa esquivo la recesión esquivó la
recesión pero lo mismo que veníamos
diciendo una cosa es lo que diga el
papel y otra cosa muy diferente es lo
que suceda en la realidad Porque mire el
dato de crecimiento económico para el
último trimestre fue revisado al alza
desde
0% a 0,1% y esto quiere decir que no
tuvo dos meses dos trimestres
consecutivos a la baja y eso se conoce
como recesión técnica cuando hay dos
trimestres consecutivos en que los que
la economía Baja pues el Reino Unido
tuvo un trimestre a la baja pero el
segundo subió apenas
0,1%. Así que pasa pero pues muy
no es muy holgado como esperarían las
autoridades no obstante esta sigue
siendo la única de las grandes potencias
que no ha recuperado su economía
prepadémica también tiene una inflación
es la inflación más alta entre sus
vecinos va en un 10,4% anual y ya
veíamos que la de la Unión Europea o de
la zona Euro mejor era mucho más baja y
aunque es posible que los británicos que
ya se están recuperando del mayor
aumento de los precios de los alimentos
desde 1977 sí es cierto que están
teniendo que acostumbrarse a la escasez
de verduras frescas ya que los costos
altísimos y el clima están afectando la
producción nacional por ejemplo en enero
pasado la importación de verduras fue la
más baja para cualquier enero desde 2010
cuando la población era un 7% más baja
que ahora Lo que sí es cierto es que el
Reino Unido sigue pagando las
consecuencias del brexit Porque además
no hay tantos trabajadores y eso impide
toda esta cadena de producción economía
que fluye mucha dificultad vamos a
cambiar de tema nuevamente los relojeros
de lujo se reúnen en Suiza a pesar de
los vientos de crisis y parece que el
panorama mejora para ellos claro y es
que muchos Pensarán que no tiene que ver
lo uno con lo otro pero en realidad si
tienen que ver y es que huaching Wonders
es una feria muy tradicional en este
país alpino y abre sus puertas al
público este fin de semana después de
toda una semana a Puerta cerrada pues
este año 48 prestigiosas marcas entre
ellas Rolex patria que Cartier mostraron
sus nuevas creaciones esto a pesar de
los recuerdos amargos que les trae la
más reciente crisis financiera que
golpeó fuertemente a la industria la
relojería suiza de lujo eleva dos lleva
dos años de ganancias récord las
exportaciones se dispararon un 31% en
2021 y el regreso del turismo de lujo a
Europa en 2022 también impulsó esas
ventas externas en un 11% adicional
hasta más de 27 mil millones de dólares
pero
lo mismo desde luego pues se ha visto
algo empañado por la angustia Que ha
rodeado al sector bancario que es una
parte clave de la economía y de la
cultura Suiza y es que después de la
ronda de quiebras bancarias que hubo en
el 2008 eso y
desencadenó una crisis financiera
mundial y las exportaciones de relojes
suizos se desplomaron un 22,3% en el
2009 lo que esperan entonces este año es
Pues que se calmen todas esas
turbulencias después de que pues va a
ser adquirido por Us y después de que
pues ya ha calmado un poquito esta este
temor en el sistema bancario y este tema
nos da para poner sobre la mesa la
palabra desigualdad no Mientras que uno
se registran ganancias récord y hay
mucho dinero para gastar en objetos de
lujo Pues en otros lugares la pobreza
sigue aumentando y Ese es nuestro último
tema Argentina donde se eleva la pobreza
si Ángela el dato del segundo trimestre
de 2022 Es que subió al 39% un poco más
del 39% casi tres puntos por encima
respecto del semestre anterior la
pobreza entonces entre junio y diciembre
del año pasado se ubicó en torno al
39,2%, Estos son 11,5 millones de
argentinos que están en situación de
pobreza estos datos los dio a conocer el
Instituto Nacional de estadística y
censos de la República Argentina y
salieron a partir de una encuesta que
abarcó a 29,3 millones de personas es
decirnos encuesta a los más de 40
millones de personas que tiene Argentina
sino en ciertas zonas pues Daniela Le
agradezco y la espero más tarde para la
actualización la última de esta semana